carbs i hate carbs well actually no i
love carbs i hate the fact though that
it's very easy to eat my body weight in
carbohydrates and get fat now when i say
carbs i know this includes everything
like fruit vegetables and grains but
some of these are complex carbohydrates
for the rest of the video when i say
carbs i'm exclusively talking about
simple carbohydrates because these tend
to contribute more to weight gain than
complex carbohydrates do i mean let's be
real for a second you could eat half a
bag of chips in one sitting but an equal
amount of brussels sprouts mmm forget it
also for the rest of the video when i
say blinkist i'm talking about the
self-improving digital learning app at
some point in the video i'm going to
explain how carbs can make you fat maybe
you're learning this for the first time
and you want to learn other ways to diet
or lose weight blinkist can help you get
there blinkus takes the key messages
from non-fiction books and puts them
together in texts this allows you to
learn the most important information you
need to know you can read and listen to
audio versions throughout the day
the first step to unlocking your brain's
potential is to change your perspective
blinkist has a huge library of
non-fiction books of different topics
like starting a business investing
history psychology and more all
condensed to help you learn more
efficiently you can even create your own
audio playlist to customize your
learning experience helping you to
sharpen your professional skills stay on
top of the latest trends and discover
new perspectives of the world the first
hundred people to go to the link in the
description are going to get unlimited
access for one week to try it out you'll
also get 25 off if you want the full
membership
say you have a low carb intake day which
is roughly between 50 to 100 grams of
carbohydrates so for breakfast that's
eggs and toast for lunch a sandwich and
an apple and dinner a side of broccoli
with some steak the carbohydrates you
ate are first broken down into simple
sugars these simple sugars are first
metabolized into glucose and then
converted into glycogen glycogen is just
a long chain of glucose molecules and
its structure makes it easier for the
body to store the body stores glycogen
primarily in two places eighty percent
in your skeletal muscles which is about
400 grams of glycogen and the remaining
20 percent is stored in your liver or
about 100 grams your skeletal muscles
need their own glycogen stores because
they perform high energy tasks like
walking running lifting and moving heavy
objects in order to do this it needs its
own on-the-spot fuel source in high
quantities oh what's that the biceps
need to curl an 80-pound barbell just
let me break off some glucose from these
glycogen stores just take this right
here
there we are convert it to atp
and voila muscle contraction glycogen is
also stored in the liver to deliver
glucose into the blood to reach the rest
of the body your organs and tissue that
are not skeletal muscle do not have
their own glycogen stores and must get
their glucose from the blood for example
when your intestines need to contract to
move digested food through it it uses
glucose from the blood to power it to
get the glucose there the liver breaks
off glucose from its glycogen stores and
sends it into the blood it makes its way
to the intestines and everyone is happy
especially you if you were constipated
now in the earlier example where your
carb intake was low your glycogen stores
did not get completely filled in terms
of weight loss this is very good the way
you gain weight is by eating too many
carbs so much that your glycogen stores
get completely filled in terms of eating
too many carbs you ate so many that
there's still glucose left over that
cannot fit in the glycogen stores this
glucose has to go somewhere your body
converts it into fatty acids and then
stores them in fat cells over time if
you continue to eat more carbs and your
glycogen stores can hold you'll continue
to allocate excess glucose into fat
cells and gain weight but just how many
grams of carbs per day is overeating
your daily carb intake well on a typical
2000 calories per day diet anything over
325 grams of carbs per day is considered
excessive carb intake but weight gain
from excessive eating is not exclusive
to carbohydrates if you eat too much
protein or fat you will gain weight it's
just that with carbohydrates it's much
easier to overeat when you eat a meal
high in protein or fat you're more
satiated and stop eating much sooner
this is because protein and fat both
higher in calories per gram than
carbohydrates take longer to be
metabolized and both are not primary
fuel sources so your body does not use
them immediately carbohydrates on the
other hand being lower in calories have
an easier digestible molecular structure
and are a primary fuel source so they're
metabolized much faster since
carbohydrates are metabolized at a
faster rate you feel hungry again after
a short period of time thereby making
you seek out more food consuming more
calories and potentially gaining more
weight it's like adding fuel to a fire
carbohydrates are similar to hay they're
light and burn quickly whereas protein
and fat are similar to logs they do have
more fuel but require more time to be
processed they have to be split up and
broken down before they can be put into
the fire which of course takes longer
than burning hay on top of that
ready-to-eat carbs that are disguised as
real food are more available and cheaper
compared to healthy or protein-rich
snacks for example if you're rushing to
work you can grab a muffin a bagel a
danish or a cereal bar even a bowl of
cereal is quick and easy and they're all
100 simple carbohydrates a bacon and egg
sandwich costs more and takes longer to
make than a simple grab-and-go breakfast
carb if you eat out a high carbohydrate
pasta is cheaper than a salmon or steak
dinner oh and don't forget the insane
amount of sugar in fruit and soft drinks
yikes even with snacking you can eat an
entire bag of chips or cookies in two
days but you can eat a whole jar of
peanut butter in the same time trust me
i've tried my point is in our modern
society it's much easier to consume two
to three times the recommended daily
intake of carbs without even trying and
on top of that live a tempting sedentary
lifestyle the most effective way to
avoid weight gain is something you've
heard over and over again diet and
exercise specifically for diet if you
have to eat simple carbohydrates because
you're in a rush or are low on cash
avoid making your diet exclusively based
on cheap simple carbohydrates complex
carbs like whole grains and oats are
high in fiber and take longer to
metabolize so you stay full longer
they're also not that much more
expensive than ready to eat simple carbs
also exercise will increase your
metabolism and reduce some of your
glycogen stores thereby avoiding the
immediate storage of glucose into your
fat cells